after the donald trump bob Corker spat
and sort of before the donald trump Jeff
Flake speech or maybe at the same time
that it was happening yesterday Donald
Trump went to Capitol Hill to have lunch
with Republican lawmakers he was double
trolled in one of the most epic
instances of trolling that we have ever
seen it starts with Thom Tillis Thom
Tillis is a Republican senator from
North Carolina he pulled off the most
epically subtle trolling of Donald Trump
he tweeted himself getting popcorn
before the meeting and then he was asked
was the popcorn for watching the fight
between Trump and corker at this meeting
and he said yeah that is why I was
preparing for the lunch with Trump and
other Republican senators the senatorial
embodiment of the grab the popcorn were
settling in for a fight I wouldn't vote
for Thom Tillis to be in charge of a
fast food restaurant but it's hilarious
and clever and how about actually
working to remove Trump from office if
you think that he's such an atrocity
Tommy Boy that's Tom Tillis that wasn't
the only trolling that took place
yesterday I read a headline yesterday
protester throws Russian flags at Trump
as he enters Republican lunch I
immediately knew it had to be our friend
Ryan Clayton and it was you might
remember Ryan Clayton because he trolled
CPAC the Conservative Political Action
Conference over the summer by handing
out Russian flags during speeches he was
eventually caught and kicked out he
tried to get Trump's son-in-law Jared
Kushner to autograph a Russian flag for
him when he was leaving a Senate hearing
before the Senate Intelligence Committee
a couple of months ago and what Ryan
Clayton did yesterday is absolutely
masterful he got himself into the
Capitol building right as Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell and
Trump were walking by and he tosses a
bunch of Russian flags at them like
confetti or rice at a Funeral I'm sorry
how did a funeral excuse me at a wedding
felt like a funeral when you saw Trump
and McConnell walk in there may be a
Freudian slip of sorts and it's funny
that the timing of the flag toss almost
makes it look like Trump is thumbs up in
the Russian flags even though obviously
was and he thumbs up every Trump uses
that thumbs up thing everywhere what was
Trump's reaction Trump assumed that
these reporter Rican flags because he
was doing such great job ten out of ten
ten with hurricane relief I'm sure
no I'm kidding around about that Ryan
got himself arrested he was charged with
unlawful conduct do you think that Trump
is at all bothered by the absurdity of
what's surrounding him or that he's even
aware of it he goes to a lunch with
lawmakers one Republican senator is
making popcorn as a total goof a
protester tosses Russian flags all over
the place it's all become a total joke
and this is exactly the type of thing
that Trump doesn't like Trump wants to
be and we know from that propaganda file
that he's given twice a day Trump wants
to be seen as the big man commanding
ultimate respect for Trump elevated
totally delusional is the reality and
this type of stuff really triggers Trump
and he got on Twitter this morning and
he tweeted the meeting with Republican
senators yesterday outside a flake and
corker was a love fest with standing
ovations and great ideas for the USA how
long can he say that right it's always
other than left-wing ideologues
everybody loves Trump other than these
two Republican senators everybody loves
Trump other than the thirty-five
Republican senators that maybe one day
will ultimately turn against Trump
people absolutely love the trumpet Genda
he's gonna use that until maybe the days
of the death of his political career and
it's hilarious and I hope that I don't
actually know what's up with Ryan I
haven't spoken to him I don't know if
he's out if he's bailed out if charges
will be dropped if he's going to be
charged prosecuted I really have no idea
we'll try to figure it out but three in
a row three russia-related
very well orchestrated trolling
instances over the summer and he is
really becoming an expert at this send
me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's program is sponsored
in part by Blue Sky binaries blockchain
Academy blockchain is the latest trend
in technology and the internet many
people unaware of the power of
blockchain on
aware of the risks carried by blockchain
technology some people think it's too
complicated to get into and so they are
staying away and missing out on both
knowledge and opportunities within the
blockchain world but it really doesn't
have to be this way and the solution is
the blue sky binary blockchain academy
blue sky binary is a leading financial
education and technology company and
they're focused on foreign exchange but
are turning their focus to blockchain
and the blue sky binary blockchain
Academy can complement the successful
training academy complete completion
it's great for both beginners within the
blockchain world as well as active
crypto users and within the course
students are taken through a series of
topics which ultimately will deliver a
solid understanding of how blockchain
works it will help the students realize
the current and potential uses of
blockchain technology which we've
covered on the program before and the
course includes video on-demand online
tests access to a community of traders
and blockchain enthusiasts who exchange
both knowledge and experiences and our
viewers and listeners at blue sky
binary.com / David can register now to
get a three day free trial which
includes access to the first module of
the blockchain academy course you can
evaluate it decide if it's right for you
stick with it or cancel anytime and
resume whenever you want to once again
get that three-day free trial of the
blockchain academy at blue sky
binary.com / David